हुआ था नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि
ने इस एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज से
नेक्स्ट चाहिए एपिसोड हम थोड़े कंपलेक्स
सेंटेंस बनाना कंपलेक्स स्ट्रक्चर्स बनाना
सीखने वाले हैं तो आप इसकी शुरुआत में
थोड़ी सिंपलर कंसेप्ट से करते हैं वह है
10,000 पॉइंट्स हैं आधार अ कंजक्शन यह
कंजंक्शंस है बेसिकली एडवर्स है तो इसको
यूज कैसे करना है हम देखते हैं बेसिकली
डेथ आल्मंड या फिर हिंदी में होगा इसलिए
इसलिए और ट्रोड्डेन बेसिकली इन आंवले
हिंदी में होगा फिर भी फिर भी तो उसको यूज
कैसे करते हैं हम देखते हैं बहुत सिंपल
यूज है 2 सेकंड जॉइन करने हैं थोड़ा सा
चेंज चाहिए पूर्व सबसे पहले हम सिंपल मुझे
चाय पसंद है इसलिए मैं चाय पीता हूं आई
लाइक टीम देर फॉर राइटिंग थिस सिंपल है तो
वह पहला सेंटेंस का यह मागते दूसरा
सेंटेंस क्या होगा इस ट्रिक खट्टे करें
व्रत जोड़ों के तो क्या होगा यह सिर्फ देश
भारत बीच में आएगा और
मैं आपको यार क्या रखने में कोई सिंपल कि
देता हूं कि वह 10 साल सेकंड सेंटेंस का
पाठ बनेगा 10 साल सेकंड सेंटेंस का पार्ट
बनेगा तो फिर अगर सेट द सेकंड सेंटेंस का
पार्ट बना तो पहले प्रश्न पर 10 साल पाया
है तो दूसरी घोषित किया जाना चाहिए वह इसी
लिए इस मास्क तहसील प्रियंका इश्ते बहुत
सिंपल इस मारते 10 साल प्रिंटर इंस्टेंट
और एक्सिडेंट बनाते हैं क्यों भारत को
संडे है आज तो संडे है इसलिए मैं काम नहीं
करता
कि टुडे इस संडे आईडी सेंड ए दश फॉर थे
डोर टो वर्क तो क्या होगा ऐसे जॉइंट आखिर
इस अपडेटर नेक्स्ट जोड़ना है क्या होगा 10
साल पहले आएगा दूसरी पूजन करवावै गा ऐड
डोंट ID स्थल पर बटर इश कुंठ एकदम सिंपल
एडिट अब इसका उल्टा कि मैं आपको अगर बोलना
है कि वही मुझे तो काफी पसंद है फिर भी
मैं चाहेगी
में आए लाइव कॉफी न धरई साइडिंग टीम तो
बाकी सब स्ट्रक्चर सेम रहेगा इस ट्रिक इस
मार्ग का फैले इस ट्रिक कटे जोड़ने को ए
बिट रखेंगे तो क्या होगा इस मास्क काफी
रॉटर ड्रिंक पी इस तेल सिंपल है वैसे ही
पसंद शेष फिर भी मैं काम करता हूं संडे
फिर भी मैं काम करता हूं इंस्टंट लेख
फोन नंबर धो लें इससे क्या होगा कि इस
संडे ए प्वाइंट आईएस अबाउट इसमें आएगा
ट्रक स्टैंड टेस्टिस जॉइंट आखरोट सेवर
बैटर इसको एकदम सिंपल है राइड कोई भी मतलब
ऐसे हार्ड नहीं है तो डिफरेंस क्या है कि
कुत्ते थाल और ट्रोड्डेन जो था उसे
कंपोजिट सेकंड सेंटेंस में उसका पार्ट बना
इसीलिए वर्स्ट पोजीशन क्या हुआ है तो उसे
कंडीशन पर आज यह मैंने जान-बूझकर सीखा है
लेकिन नेक्स्ट जब नेक्स्ट कंसेप्ट जो यह
बहुत इंपोर्टेंट कंसीडर्ड व्हाईल
ट्रैवलिंग इन कॉन्टेक्स्ट टो रंग की जो
लाइनर साइड अंदर रिजल्ट्स हो गया है उनमें
यह आपको बहुत यूज होने वाला है अगर आपको
यह सब समझ में आई है तो तो अगर तो उनके
पास बाकी सब तो एकदम नॉर्मल ऐसे और थोड़े
कनेक्टर्स हैं बेस्ट वैगनर लो जिनका
मीनिंग ऑलमोस्ट विशाल जैसा ही है या फिर
जॉन स्ट जॉन्स मतलब अदरवाइज वह तू नहीं
आएगा टाइम पर तो मैं चला जाऊंगा 12.1
ज्यादा यूज़ नहीं करता
आपके लिए सिर्फ यह देख अ आपको सिर्फ
कैरियर 10 साल और टिफिन समझ में आई है तो
बॉडी न आगे एक छोटी सी चीज की कुछ लोग
मजबूत वैश्विक रुख के बीच में कैमरा देखकर
आप भी इस साल स्माल लिख सकते हो या फिर अ
पुख्त मतलब उक्त देखकर डिफिकल्ट करके
नेक्स्ट सेंटेंस चालू कर सकते हैं वह
धरमजयगढ़ ओके गुड प्रॉब्लम ठीक है तो आए
हो कि सबको यह कंजर्व समझ में आई होगी
नेक्स्ट पाठ में मिलते हैं थोड़ी ज्यादा
कांटेक्ट के साथ धन्यवाद